has Captain compressed oh man that's  such a good question maybe with like  what does he do man probably has like a  nice old-fashioned with a nice piece of  fish hey something real the hokey and  simple I'll be like the way like an old  guy just kind of unwinds live music like  the Hollywood Bowl and go and see you  know Harlan Oates covers earth when  invited that's kind of what the Falcon  do but who don't like haulin oats Bucky  was just wandering around town going I  know I've been on this path my thing is  if I make a left it will lead me to  cobble stone where's that be I am you  can take it  I could do anything I McCain so I mean  it could be sports it could be a bath in  a waterfall like anything the vision  loss is a short-order cook and a diner  on the weekends really very kind of  yogic kind of like give me another order  all my fresh mex fry some eggs rice and  eggs  you